number one route 72 from here you can
see there's a big square number I can
check out of it what can you see 36 the
square root of 36 I can pull it up
the square root of 9 can also put up at
36 is bigger so you might as well do
that if you can see it if I take the
square root of 36 our
what is the screen 36 6 6 so this is 6
root there's also a square you can take
out of this namely or 4 very good so I'm
going to take the square root of 4 out
the square root of 4 is 2 so 4 times 2
is 8
do you agree with that that's just the
number at the front once I've taken the
square root of 4 out there what's left
underneath the square root over 2 and
that's why like you see you know 6 over
here take away 8 of them that's why you
have minus 2 of them at the end that
make sense okay second one actually a
little bit easier so you can see Leo a
secret five times root 10 he's seen
route 50 has a big square number you can
take out namely 25 very good so he's
taking the skirts when you find out
there it is right there at the front
Brito is left behind there's not much
that required is required here you can't
taking square numbers out of root 10 so
you don't write let's finish this out
there let's do all the working this time
since I don't have anything to go off I
know do these one at a time with my
pairs of terms ok so root six times four
and two what would you like me to write
for a 12 which you might be thinking I
can simplify that in the next line so
we'll come to that in a minute
root 6 times 3 3 root 6
you can't thank you there's not much I
can do with that so that's fine and then
I'm gonna do the second pair now don't
forget both of them have a minus 5
attached to them so this will become
minus 1 1 is 20 root 2 we remember that
our whole numbers out the front we deal
with and then our serves we do it
separately so that gives you 20 what are
here in here
- 15 mm okay and when you have a look
down the list this is fine this is also
fine can't take any other have a dis
fine it's just this guy that you need to
muck around with so what's going on
would you like me to take out four so
the square root of 4 will be 2 so 2
times 8 what does that leave you with on
the inside 3 so now when you have a look
at the whole thing is there anything I
can collect together I'm done that's it
okay are you happy
the head is rationalizing the
denominator that's the way that you read
this bit of a mouthful I just want you
to think for a moment about all of the
fractions that you've ever had to deal
with now when you work with fractions
when you work with fractions and you
look at the denominators of those
fractions we want a couple of things so
if I gave you a fraction like say 6 over
8 6 over 8 most of you would
instinctively say I can write that
simpler how can you write 6 over 8 in a
simpler way you could go 3 or 4 right
because both of them we might just write
example both of them are divisible by 2
yeah so you divide that both by 2 and
that gives you an equivalent fraction
right
so we want what what is it that makes
this better than this we want it to be a
smaller number a smaller denominator as
possible so we want the smallest
denominator
can anyone give me a reason why small
the denominators are objectively better
than bigoted nominees like what's wrong
with 6 over 8
why is 3/4 better than six separate hmm
well if for example I was adding this
guy to some other fractions don't write
this but if I like adding this together
with something like this this is the
same fraction now you can see you know
how you do that exercise with working
out common denominators write comments
in a minute is it might not be
immediately obvious to you that these
will have the same common denominator
once you simplify stuff out but if you
write each of them with the smallest
denominator possible then you'll say oh
this is 3/4 this is also 3/4 so you
don't need to change those denominators
at all you don't have to say ooh what's
8 times 400 hmm
3,200 and then you change all of these
the numbers get bigger bigger it becomes
more and more confusing
that's why smaller denominators better
something else that you might have seen
before not very common but if I said to
you okay here's a fraction 3 over 2
takeaway okay yeah can you tell me
what's that equal to can you tell me at
least what the next step is yeah okay
this is a nominator I can combine those
terms Conner so that's going to be 3
over negative 3 right which in turn is
negative 1 ok now in this case you can
see it's just if we and having that
negative sign on the denominator right
so not only do we like to have small
denominators we also like to have
positive denominators you've actually
rewritten this number with a positive
denominator namely 1 ok so we want small
denominators we also want positive
denominators
okay whether to smaller
mr+ I am going to add one more thing to
the to the mix and I can't give you an
example just yet that's what the rest of
this board will be about no they do want
them to be small and positive but it
would also be nice we want rational
denominators in other words we want to
avoid certs and other kinds of
irrational things on the denominators
for all the same reasons that you just
noticed before it's hard to work with
the denominators if they're not rational
right as an example you can write this
paper on the right hand side if I said
to you what are these two names right
that's really troublesome to deal with
you're gonna get a bit of a mess when
you try and put these two things
together but if they're both rational
five and seven set a root 5 root 7 this
would be much much easier so underneath
that you can make a little subheading
which is how now in fact I am gonna
steal this example yeah if you wanted to
add these two together how do I change a
fraction so that it's previously
irrational to nobody can become rational
Lodge okay very good
did you notice the thing you can do with
fractions I'm here is if you multiply
the top of the bottom by the same thing
it's still the same number do you agree
like I can multiply through these
numbers by two fraction hasn't changed
it just looks a bit different so what
I'm gonna do is either take this guy and
if I multiply the top and the bottom by
as delage suggestion to define the same
denominator I'm gonna get 3 root 5 on
the top what will I get on the
denominator 5 because root 505 that's
the number that when you multiply
by itself gives you five what about the
amount of traction
how could I rationalize that it's
forward for on route 7 so if I multiply
the top and the bottom by root seven
then on the bottom I won't have an
irrational in number anymore I'm gonna
have seven so maybe if you like I'll put
it in the e2b that line just to help you
see it right this guy here is three on
route 5 I'm gonna multiply the top by
root 5 which means I've been multiply
the bottom by nerve fibers well why
don't you do that because rational
denominator is just like positive ones
and small ones are easier for me to deal
with ok I can compute with them a lot
more quickly I'd have to think about
third balls I can just think about them
as regular fractions so I did that to
the first number I did the same thing to
the second one
it used to be 4 over root 7 so I
multiply the top and the bottom by roots
like which leads me to this line alright
so what I have done is I've changed the
denominators so that they're not
irrational anymore they're rational now
which is why it's called rationalizing
the donut you could potentially if you
wanted to you from here you could now
add these what common denominator would
you choose from these two factions you
just a 5 right
so I'd multiply this one by 7 over 7 so
it would become 21 root 5 on 35 what I
multiply this one by okay yes but no I'm
actually multiplying by 5 over 5 do you
agree because otherwise I'm actually
changing the fraction but 5 over 5 is
just 1 so it doesn't change the value so
that's going to become 20 roots
on 30 final it's a decade top and bottom
top employer I've run out of space on
the bottom with my boy heat but now that
they're both over 35 I can just combine
there's two things at the top
why certainly okay
sorry I ran out of space to write that
message every dinner okay but let's
distribute if you get given a pair of
fraction and one or both of them have
irrational denominators certs then if
you just multiply by the right sir
you'll turn them into rational turnovers
generally you want the poll numbers and
that you can do whatever you want with
that fraction you can combine them and
so on
here are two fractions 302 7 on 3 root 5
what they want us to do is rationalize
that denominator of each one so let's
have a look at this one first I'm gonna
multiply the top and the bottom by
something that will change the
denominator to be a rational number not
a certain move so can someone tell me
what should I multiply by whatever 1
root 2 over root 2 okay so you can see
on the top just like always with
fractions you're gonna have 3 times root
2 that's good what do I get on the
denominator - that's it done skis it's
rational I've finished right
have a look at this one I'm not gonna
tonight then yet I want to multiply by
something there was something so that I
make the denominator rational now what's
the irrational part it's just refine so
I'm gonna run x through five of every
five now this is going to get us an
additional step just watch what happens
numerator 7 root 5 that's not hot but on
the denominator don't forget this 3 over
here you still hanging out there it
doesn't disappear so it's gonna be 3
times 5 which is occasionally
occasionally their particular
combinations it says you've got will
mean that I might have some extra
simplifying to do like if that was 6 for
example you were to simplify that
earlier by the 6 and 15 have a common
factor and you could cancel them